from cbs12.com
NBC reporters interview with PA Senate
candidate John fetterman draws criticism
so in this interview with NBC fetterman
who's running he's a democrat in
Pennsylvania
he can't actually understand the words
that are being said to him because in
may he suffered a very serious stroke
and it was debilitating and it caused
him very serious brain damage I'm not
saying that as a as a pejorative or to
be disrespectful he literally is
suffering from this actually in the
interview let me uh let me play it here
let's I'm not gonna I don't care to play
her audio they show in the uh I think I
just passed that actually
so let's uh let me see if I can play it
and uh well you know I'll pull the audio
up
are you confident going into that debate
debate it's it's going to be so they do
editing because uh here you go there you
go in this image you can see right here
in order for fetterman to actually
answer the questions they have a special
program that transcribes the word she's
saying into written text so we can read
it and then answer
this led to a whole bunch of people
saying he's clearly not mentally fit to
do the job how is he going to stand on
the senate floor and debate an idea when
people are saying John you are wrong
your bill would do X Y and Z and he goes
I I can't understand anything I can hear
the words but my brain can't press it
this is not someone being deaf a bunch
of these woke journalists Democrats and
liberals were like we don't discriminate
against people who can't hear he can
hear he can hear perfectly his brain
cannot process the audio that to me is
very very serious yeah I'll tell you
this man
they voted for Joe Biden hopefully
hopefully they learned their lesson I
think a lot of people will have learned
the lesson I think a lot of people won't
but to all these people I say to you you
voted for Joe Biden right you thought
how bad can it really be how bad can
it's it's better than Trump when you
vote for someone who is cognitively
impaired you get disaster you get crisis
you get deficits you get shutting down
of Keystone and now gas prices are
skyrocketing and then a weird
justification in the media that shutting
down and curtailing U.S energy had
nothing to do with the fact that gases
is skyrocketing and now six seven bucks
in California if you vote in this man
and I I I feel bad for him I mean no
disrespect I mean a stroke is serious I
feel bad and I hope I wish him the best
but we need people who are physically
and mentally capable to do the job I
think they'll vote for him though well
it's not only only that outside of
politics if you suffer a serious brain
injury you gotta rest you gotta relax
you got to give your your brain time to
heal correctly and just by shoving him
into the camera shoving him on stage all
the time that's not not good for an
individual who suffered a severe
injury to to his mind and you know if
people really did care about this
individual If people really were looking
out for his best interest they would be
making sure he healed correctly before
putting him up putting them up there on
the stage yeah yeah I mean I Had a Brain
Injury as well I had a brain injury in
2015 I fell asleep driving and hit an
accident response vehicle on the road
and I cannot even imagine being put on
stage let alone you know having to be
representative for people that are
voting me into Power into the United
States like I remember he was running
for the house Congress for what he's
running for now but I would never want
to be in that situation it would be
unbelievably hell it should be extremely
stressful because just coming out of
that is already such a challenge so what
did you do to recover
um I spent some time with my parents
actually in the UK funnily enough
um but uh I it took me I would say you
feel like you're recovered after about a
year two years but you really only
realized maybe five years later that wow
okay now I'm fully recovered from my
brain injury so I honestly can't even
remember or imagine what he's going
through right now not to give you know
give him quarter or anything like that
but I would never never put myself in a
situation where I'm being a
representative for other people let
alone you know being forced to read to
respond to everything that's wild yeah
wild a lot of soldiers on the front
lines of battlefields are told to not be
on the battlefield for too long because
of the concussions and the shooting and
the grenades and the explosions and the
sounds literally Rock their heads to the
point where they get serious brain
injuries they're told literally get off
the battlefield go into a dark quiet
room and make sure there's no stimuli
make sure you could actually rest and
relax your brain so when you're put on
stage when you're being quizzed during
an interview when you're taking
questions from individuals you're not
allowing your brain to to rest when you
can't even interpret sounds you're not
allowing your brain to rest so it's just
a sad situation overall and it's sad
seeing him slur his words and you know a
lot of people are using this for
political uh you know talking points but
it's beyond that I think it is but but
come on the dude should have dropped out
the Democratic party should have said
look man you had a stroke I'm sorry but
I think as much as I can say I'm sorry
to the man for having a stroke and I
wish him the best where I will criticize
him heavily is his arrogance his
arrogance and thinking I'm gonna keep
going
okay man you we we see what happens with
Joe Biden and now you're gonna get it in
Pennsylvania when you when when the
people vote for this guy it's gonna be
bad he's going to be in a meeting and
someone's gonna say something like
there's an emergency and we have to act
now there's a crisis on the bridge he's
going to be going
I don't know what you're saying you need
to call it in now we've got a flood
there's damage there's people dying can
someone get a cc machine in here so I
can understand what do you do we I I'm
sorry man this is a guy look I get it
he's running for Senate he's not running
for uh you know he's lieutenant governor
now that's bad enough he should have
resigned I don't know if he's still in
that position
but he's going to be on the senate floor
and they're going to be saying there's
an emergency they're going to bring him
in and they're going to they're going to
have to get him a special computer look
technology is fantastic
before this technology existed even
maybe 10 years ago
he'd he'd be done that's it sorry have a
nice day you can't understand words
being said to you can't do this job and
because of Technology we've invented
that can transcribe words into text
which is a relatively new thing he is
now saying okay I can do it yo I have
tried using transcript transcription
software there have been many
circumstances where like Biden's giving
a speech and I need to grab like a chunk
of the quote and I'm like I gotta write
this down so what I'll try to do is I'll
I'll download voice to text or I'll use
the internal voice to text and it's full
of errors and what happens when someone
says something like imagine this person
saying listen here my sister and then it
says Mister instead of my sister there's
like a words get jumbled too quickly and
then he's reading it and he reads the
wrong thing and gives a bad answer right
yeah they make mistakes all the time
it's not perfect technology it's it's
new technology you know when whenever
you have captions even on social media
you have to look through every single
word because there could be a big
mistake there that the algorithm could
find and pick up and automatically ban
you for even using specific words on a
lot of the social media platforms
imagine but but I just kind of want to
point out is it really him or is it the
people behind him because again this is
a man who suffered a serious injury does
he even like how how aware of he is of
the current situation and a lot of
people when they're injured they they
don't want to see themselves as injured
they a lot of times they don't want to
heal they don't want to rest so so he
might be pushed by other individuals by
other interests who are saying this is
too much of an important race for us to
lose there might be a democratic machine
special interest big money saying hey we
invested in you we want our payout we we
don't care go out there on stage sing a
dance for us because a lot of politics
is that big money controlling
individuals to be their puppets
politicians are puppets in my opinion
and and to me there's a lot of puppet
hands behind this major race that the
whole nation is looking at here's
another uh interesting tidbit
he probably could he could watch this
podcast of us critiquing and and talking
about his health and he wouldn't
understand it at all the closed
captioning auto-generated on on these
videos or whatever for you know I'm
thinking like what if what if Ben
Shapiro was trying to tell him something
talks fast he does so you get someone
like you know imagine someone says John
you got to watch the latest uh daily
wire with Ben Shapiro he says a bunch of
things you need to you know you'll want
to be apprised of and
he's been talking about really really
fast there's a prominent issue when it
was a taxes in the United States
government we got all these Senators
that are coming in and he's going to be
like the The Voice the text doesn't work
on this it's really sad you know I'm
thinking the whole time like yeah but
maybe it can work and I I don't I don't
think it can I don't think it can work
we're not there yet
yeah I can understand why he'd want to
do it and I understand do you think he's
more likely to win now though well right
now the aggregate polling has him six
points up but we've seen from Paul
aggregate polling in the past several
elections a seven point swing in favor
of Democrats so it looks like it may
actually go to Dr Oz and NBC in this
interview said the race is now a toss-up
look I think the average person in
Pennsylvania is sitting there going like
I'm sorry dude you know I like you but
you can't do the job right I look if I
if I need to hire someone to pick up
Boulders and you show up and you're in a
wheelchair what am I supposed to do I
mean I don't even know what the legality
is on that but if you can't pick up a
boulder how do I hire you to pick up a
boulder if we're hiring a person to
argue debate and push policy and he
can't understand the words that are
being said to him how do you how does he
do the job I'm shocked that he that he's
demanding that people actually support
him in that in that regard yeah that's
what bothers me I want to like him and I
don't because of his arrogance was a
good word actually it's arrogance yeah
it's really annoying my hand but I'm
playing the guitar you can't stop me
pull back bro and then run again in like
four years you can run again run when
your body's rested and healthy do a
float tank I don't know if psilocybin's
right for you do something to help
repair neural Pathways you're okay but
don't don't take on this responsibility
right now right there have been some
studies with with psychedelic mushrooms
showing that they could actually heal uh
some kind of brain damage I'm not a
doctor I'm not here trying to give any
medical advice but there are some
preliminary studies that I think are
worthwhile to look at it's called
neurogenesis and it's how you regrow
brain cells it's the function of
regrowing brain cells you can do it John
modern politics but I think that's
illegal though I think that's illegal in
Pennsylvania yeah you need to work with
a doctor Colorado I think in Washington
DC it's legal really yep like psilocybin
recreationally or medically um
additionally I know someone taking it in
Washington DC right now I think Colorado
it's recreational right and or Oregon
yeah well or all drugs are
decriminalized in Oregon so you can find
it really yeah is that what's going on
in Portland uh I think so that's part of
what's going on in Portland that that
must be it that explains everything you
got a whole bunch of people showing up
wearing all black summer on shrooms I'm
running acid some smoke too much some
drank too much some injected too much
sounds like it and it's all just uh
I think some people did it all I think
it's a lot more complicated than that
especially with George soros's
involvement but that's another topic to
discuss here I think Switzerland is also
that way and I think they've got I
remember reading about they've got these
little sort of cabins in in their parks
where you can go and I don't know on
your on this channel if you can say but
the H that you inject
um heroin you say that yeah yeah Sean
doesn't let me say that on his channel
um you can inject heroin you like go in
and like it's all clean and you just go
and inject you know there's someone
there to help you administer it and harm
reduction that's what they do though
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there